the world economy poses us a riddle
these days crises sanctions dropping oil
prices and sluggish growth and at the
same time nonetheless
a large number of data a large number of
news that do spread optimism
oliver raka from deutsche bank research
is here with me to clarify things to
straighten out things a little bit mr
rocco let's have a look at the debix
first that represents the economic mood
in the four biggest economies in the
world what is the debix telling us the
dmx has fallen slightly in november
this has been largely due to moderation
of sentiment in the united states the
ism has fallen a bit but still on a high
level otherwise we did have a rise in
the efo index for example in november
but this came after six declines and so
far we are still cautious to see this as
a turnaround necessarily
but all told even japan and also china
have seen
robust readings but all told still
the dbx as well as the individual
indicators point to moderate growth at
best unfortunately moderate growth
the stock markets don't really
seem to care about that very much the
ducks was down at 8 400 just about six
weeks ago is up at 10 000 points now
similar story with uh with the dow jones
in in new york
investors um seem to be in an excellent
mood there how do you explain that stock
market rush
that's due to several factors the most
important factors are definitely
central banks
and better growth data lately for one
there was a discussion about the united
states
and their central bank already rising
raising their interest rate early 2015
this expectation has been slow towards
mid-2015 by now and so far
the stimulus is here to stay longer in
the us and in europe we've gotten
increasing expectations and hopes
definitely for the ecb to do even more
for example doing public qe purchases of
government bonds all this added to each
other and also we had kind of a growth
scale in the course of q3
with weak growth numbers especially in
germany
this has
weakened sentiment on the financial
markets but the latest data has been
more stable partly positive and so far
the ducks bounce back
we will talk about the world economy
these days of course we have to talk
about the oil prices oil price is down
is still dropping
basically in free fall christine lagarde
the imf
managing director is saying that a low
oil price is not even such a bad
thing for the world economy how do you
see that that's um we agree
we think that's definitely a growth
upside for next year
because it increases the purchasing
power of households lowers cost basis
for a lot of companies
and so far
that might well be one of the positive
factors going into next year
on the other hand you always have to
keep in mind that a lot of countries are
all exporters and these might restrict
their consumption their imports and
especially their investment part of that
could be in the united states where
shale
oil shale gas have been an important
driver of investment lately if this
crumbles now
due to lower oil prices this might have
at least moderating effect on the
positive
real income effect
with the eurozone with eurozone or
europe's growth we need to be a little
more patient
that is true we have seen an increase in
growth finally positive growth numbers
middle of last year
but growth has been weak fragile uneven
as mario draghi keeps on saying and it's
definitely true
there is no clear growth path ahead for
europe yet
some countries have found their
turnaround spain portugal greece all of
them started growing again but italy and
france are definitely lagging behind
currently and so far
we are not really seeing much better
growth prospects in europe next year it
has indeed been quite an eventful year
for europe's economy in our focus
interview this month we want to recap
and to look back on europe's economic
year 2014
you can find that online on dw de slash
english slash mage in germany